el sueño se hace realidad para Kevin
mccarthy por fin puede dirigir la sesión
118 del Congreso de los Estados Unidos
como presidente de la cámara de
representantes mi responsabilidad última
no es para con mi partido mi conferencia
o incluso nuestro congreso mi
responsabilidad nuestra responsabilidad
es para con nuestro país
para hacerse con el mazo de presidente
el californiano tuvo que sufrir 14
humillantes derrotas en las votaciones
de la cámara el Capitolio se convirtió
en el teatro de un bochornoso drama
político
durante la décimo cuarta Ronda de
votaciones se registraron algunas
escenas increíbles en un momento dado
mccarthy se enfrentó a Matt Gates de
Florida quien se encontraba sentado
junto a Lauren bubbled de Colorado dos
de los últimos residentes de la veintena
de miembros del freedom Cocos el grupo
republicano más derechista que había
estado bloqueando su candidatura esta
semana la batalla por la presidencia de
mccarthy se convirtió en un embarazosa
guerra interna para el partido
republicano que ganó el control de la
cámara en las elecciones de mitad de
mandato con una mayoría muy ajustada
hizo tantas concesiones a los partidos
de la línea dura para ganarse sus votos
que Gates llegó a bromear con que su
bloque se estaba quedando sin cosas que
pedir
el hombre de goma no tiene principios
seguros lo único que le importa es
conseguir la presidencia probablemente
será el portavoz más débil de la
historia moderna del país y será rehén
de estos 20 o 21 republicanos radicales
la elección de presidente de la cámara
representantes más largas desde el siglo
XIX es otro revés para la democracia
estadounidense tuvo lugar en el mismo
edificio que fue atacado por una turba
de partidarios de Trump hace dos